you are neighbors next door neighbors  with Zac Efron that's right and some  people okay girls that were you want to  start or bus how did you find that out  Hannah I was stalking Zac Efron and I  saw you go out the door next door for  yogurt know people whoo that but it's  actually not a great thing when you when  you're next door to a big celebrity  because the paparazzi camps out for that  person and then you get bug does that  happen to you uh it's more like strange  teenage girls writing love letters and  confusing my gate I've a gate but my  date with his gate so I'll get these  like strange letters covered in hearts  like I love you Zach and you're the  greatest and I don't know what to do  with them so I'm just I'm putting them  all up a wall in my house that would  really make a mess on my real shrine  yeah  you